we're doing something a little different
again today I'm going to be speaking to
dr. Peter Boghossian who's a full-time
faculty member in Portland State
University's philosophy department as
well as author of the book a manual for
creating atheists on our full program
today our regular sort of daily
political stories are going to be on
today's bonus show so yet more incentive
to become a subscriber to the David
Pakman show Peter it's always great to
talk to you I want to start first
digging into a book a manual for
creating atheist in a little more detail
and and as you know I'm going to be
using portions of that book in an
upcoming course I'll be teaching as an
adjunct professor at Boston College so
certainly I think that there's huge
value to this book but there's some
ideas in it I'd love to dig in to a
little more with you and to start maybe
you could familiarize the audience with
how you define faith in the book for the
purposes of exploring it further okay if
it's okay I'd like to take a step back
from that and talk about what the
purpose of the book is who are the
purpose of the book is to this one big
word in the whole book and that's
epistemology and that basically means
how you know what you know the purpose
of the book is to help people become
more reflective to examine their
epistemology is to examine the way they
know things and it's to help people
engage in civil conversations and there
are now literally hundreds of more than
thousands of these online and YouTube in
which people take the techniques from
the book as a template and personalize
that right have conversations with other
people about their metaphysical beliefs
faith based basically any beliefs so
that being said faith has many many
definitions
Loftis described unlocks describes as
leap over probabilities as pretending to
know something you don't know as
insufficient evidence to warrant belief
in a claim but yet you decide to believe
anyway there are many many definitions
of faith first Peter I mean the Hebrews
111 has a definition in the Bible of
faith the cronniss faith is not
explicitly defined evidence of things
unseen is the unhoped-for and a couple
with hope so the the there are many many
definitions and among the most important
thing in these conversations is that we
clarify what we mean by our terms right
from the get-go so how do you define
faith what are the two ways you define
faith in the book our define faith as I
think I defined faith through three or
four days but pretending to know things
you do not know phrase is also believing
anyway I know you asked me for two but
it's hard to pin a doubts to believing
anyway when you're going to believe
something just because you want to
believe it basically because your moral
mind over override your rational mind
well belief and if without evidence was
the other one I was thinking of in
addition blue pretending to know things
you don't know yeah belief about
sufficient evidence sufficient is a key
word there because you can have evidence
for a lot of things but that's not
sufficient to warrant a confidence in a
belief my I've been thinking about the
word pretending in that first definition
you gave pretending to know things you
don't know I don't know that that's that
common I mean a lot of people are
probably not pretending that they more
than likely in based on the
conversations I've had with people they
believe things that you and I might say
you can't actually know that based on
the available evidence so talk about
your decision to include the word
pretending to know things you don't know
if that was the case why would they have
crises of faith why does everybody say
they have Christ you don't have a crisis
that a pencil sharpener exists or no I
think that's fair but that that still
doesn't mean at some point one might
have a realization all this time I've
believed to know things that were not
supported by evidence but it's still
very difficult to say that at any point
someone is pretending to know something
they don't know I don't know I'm just
sort of throwing it out there yeah no no
it's a totally legitimate reasonable
question I had I am you know Ryan
Bella's the guy who tried to live
without God for a year and then became
an atheist now he's an interesting guy
he does here's a movie that's coming on
about that journey of it different he
just tried to live a year without God he
was a pastor in LA at a
we had a formidable flock to use that
word and then he decided to try to live
a year without God and I had a
conversation with him he is a a movie
coming out directed by and Emory Emory
be out any time now about his journey
and he he pressed me on that and I would
urge people to watch that conversation
because at the end of the conversation
he said yeah you know what I
I really didn't know and I had gaps in
my understanding of things and I made
those gaps up and I'm paraphrasing
obviously I made those gaps up by
pretending and and I'm not saying
everybody is pretending I think that
there are certainly some people who are
suffering from legitimate religious
delusions about talking snakes and you
know what have you these people aren't
pretending they're actually delusional
but but many people I can't give you a
percentage but many people pretend to
know something and I gave a talk on this
and at the greater humanist of Portland
it's online I think it's called faith
pretending to know things you don't know
where I lay out and explain the
differences that's why people by the way
make that leap between mixing up the
definition of faith with hope and trust
and they do that because there's you
don't have to pretend anything when you
hope for some you know for anything I
want
Sam Harris's I can hope for a diamond
the size of refrigerator in my own
backyard but I need to pretend that when
you have faith in something you have
confidence it extends beyond the warrant
of evidence and to make up for that
confidence you need something usually
that something is faith and usually
people that little gap that little space
in there between the evidence you have
and the confidence you have in that
belief has to be made up somehow I think
that's interesting because from my
perspective I mean as you know and most
of my audience knows I'm basically on
board with what it is we're talking
about here and your point of view but I
do think that there are sometimes more
gray areas than I like to admit when it
comes to faith and evidence and just to
sort of put this idea out there in some
sense
couldn't we say any inductive reasoning
requires some of what we might
colloquially describe as faith and I'll
give an example right so if I were to
make an assertion like I have faith that
Jesus Christ is God or whatever right
that's pretty clear to to you and to me
as yeah a basic epistemological
intervention of the types you you sort
of walk people through in your book can
get many people to reconsider that
particular faith statement but in the
same way we might believe a gravity is
uniform across our universe we don't
really have what I would even call
substantial evidence for that we've
studied or observed like a tiny fraction
of the universe we're using inductive
reasoning and if we really look at sort
of the philosophical definition of
knowledge a justified true belief that
might be a faith type belief that
gravity functions the same way across
our universe wouldn't it uh well we
really don't pack that that's a lot
there Sean Carroll the physicist Sean
Carroll calls it with that idea that
there that does a in Victor Stenger also
had roots inside well that that there's
a uniformity of gravity look first of
all in our physicist so I can't resort
but conceptually I think it applies
right right right but we wouldn't we
wouldn't say that we had faith we would
say we have a suspicion our confidence
that we can extrapolate from this corner
of the universe and the physical
phenomena gravitational waves etcetera
found in this corner of the universe
that we can extrapolate from that and
say that there's a universality of that
here's the difference and this was a big
lightbulb moment for me yes um people
usually use this to say well you have
faith your wife loves you
all right so let's I'm just going to
back away just for a moment and I'll get
back to the induction for sure yep
the issue with then is that your wife is
a real person who lives with you
we don't have anything there's even
people David's a lot of people do
Fitzgerald Bob price et cetera who cast
doubt on historicity of Jesus
now once there one more thing that's not
how religious people use the word faith
yes let me give you a big the what I
don't know let me just attempt it
because I'm just I'm I think we might be
deviating from maybe the point I was
going to I understand that religious
people might define faith differently
but I guess what I'm saying is the way
you and I would define faith I feel like
as someone who again is mostly on board
with your assertions about this issue
that the line between what we know and
what requires faith is maybe not as
clear as you sometimes make it out to be
and I think your replacement of or your
use of the word suspicion is now that's
a new word where along the spectrum does
suspicion fall between faith and know
before we hold a whole week we got to
back up because this this these are huge
things that we have to unpack okay we
don't say that we have faith that the
laws of gravity apply in Alpha Centauri
or some other correct more remote we
don't say that right we say that based
on the best available evidence we assign
a confidence value to that belief you
don't even need suspicion we can take
the words suspicion is too late in any
way but we assign a confidence value to
that belief how confident we are that
belief is directly proportional to the
evidence we don't need to extend the
confidence that the warrant of belief
beyond the confidence of the evidence we
don't do that anything else we don't do
that with you know how fast jaguars run
so so why would we do why would we do
that when it comes to claims for which
we had even less evidence it makes no
sense whatsoever unless you look at
these things as moral claims as opposed
to empirical claims so like look the
problem of induction about you know we
extrapolate from the past Bertrand
Russell has some great stuff about this
we extrapolate from the past to the
future and assume that in the future the
future is going to resemble the way what
happened in the past and we do that
because we've lived in the past and we
then extrapolate from that but you don't
need any faith whatsoever from that
radishes started you know sprouting into
or where I bit into an apple and it
tasted like a roast beef sandwich sits
Bertrand Russell's example that we
wouldn't need any faith whatsoever that
faith is specifically a word that people
use when they do not have sufficient
evidence to believe something but they
believe it anyway that is the depth that
is how people actually use the term and
you don't find physicists using that
term in regard to phenomenon that happen
in remote corners of the universe
let's pause our conversation there with
dr. Peter Boghossian we will be back
after the break with plenty more we're
continuing our conversation today for
the entire hour with dr. Peter
Boghossian I want to talk a little bit
Peter about an issue that you've been
speaking about a lot over the last
couple years and this relates to
concerns about some of what's going on
in academia in the United States so I
want to start with a tweet from April of
2016 that you sent where you talked
about gender studies and you said gender
studies is primarily composed of radical
ideologues who view indoctrination as
their primary duty these departments
must be defunded
all right so least and good so I want to
break down some aspects of that first is
sort of there's an assertion you make
about radical ideologues how do we
define what is a radical ideologue and
then how do you quantify whether they
believe that their primary duty is
indoctrination in other words how did
you source that tweet or come up with
that idea okay so we're going to take
those one time so give me give me your
first question you like to pack a lot of
stuff I pack it yeah and let you add so
how do you define whether a college
professor it particularly one in gender
studies is a radical ideologue how do
you figure that out uh well not just
gender studies but anything infected by
post-modernism and Gender Studies
happens to be the most egregious example
that okay you speak you figure it out
because you look at their self that's an
awesome question but I really hope that
if anybody gets people getting nothing
out of that they just listen to that
question and then listen to this
response okay we know this because when
we look at the and I am happy to email
you some stuff about this when we look
at the course
scription these are not merely
information based courses these are
ideology mills they want people to adopt
specific views about the world about
homosexuality which basically I have as
well by the way but but these are
ideology mills in which the goal is not
to educate from the latin edge acharya
to lead out of veiling if you think
about in terms of plato's cave you're
coming from a place of Darkness place of
life you are putting beliefs into people
and we know that because not only do we
look at the course descriptions of
Gender Studies any Gender Studies
program you want and I mean literally
any and everything but we can also look
at the mission statement of
peer-reviewed journals so let's not I
want to focus because of the tweet the
tweet was about defunding Gender Studies
departments based on radical ideology
yeah what do we do about that well uh
look we can do what I tried to do which
is publish a whole paper it was a satire
on gender studies to show that that the
the emperor has no clothes we can make
this fact available to parents who are
paying tuition for their students to
become indoctrinated into these insane
ideas ok but hold on Peter Peter I think
I think we're let me slow us down
usually you're slowing me down let me
slow down a little bit I'm so in
figuring out whether a professor is a
radical ideologue you said you look at
whether the syllabus includes ideology
rather than teaching or how do you
determine that like what would be an
example of a syllabus that would
indicate we're dealing with a rat not a
syllabus this is way beyond a syllabus
ok it's just a departments mission
statement ok this is a mission statement
and I would look it up right now but
we're live on camera but this is what
they're this isn't me I want to make
crystal clear about that this is not me
saying this this is them says this is in
their own words what they want to do
they are activists look how many times
the word activism appears in their
course descriptions these people
self-described as activists and on what
basis on what basis should an academic
it'd be funded or not well based upon
whether or not their conclusions accord
with reality I don't buy things well I
also think we should do fun theology
departments as well well look okay so
there is a broad spectrum of this at one
and you have theoretical physicists who
are positing ideas about the nature of
universe unified field theory as string
theory all the stuff that I don't
understand okay
and the argument has been made that
that's there's not enough evidence about
okay great but these people aren't
claiming to know this these are not huge
look here's a difference Daniel Dennett
said it best philosophy the discipline
that I'm in when you work in philosophy
you should be doing work of abiding
significance
those are Dennis terms that he uses in a
little paper called chyme SCH M ESS
chess with the mess in it the difference
between somebody wasting their time
working on issues of non abiding
significance is it really doesn't the
papers incited it really doesn't make
any difference I think I heard a lecture
in which 80% of papers and humanities
are only cited one time if at all zero
to one times gender studies and in
disciplines infected by post-modernism
are different in that they are morally
motivated so it's not just that they
total their thumbs and work away on
esoteric problems how many grains of
sand and heat and things like this but
they they work to radicalize and
galvanize people into moral ways of
viewing the world and I would argue that
if you look at the madness emanating
from colleges today it can be directly
traced back to post-modernism in general
and Gender Studies and civics
they are heated I guess my question I
guess is I think we have a thing sorry I
think they are solely responsible for
intersectionality the worst plague
that's affecting us right now yeah I
mean I've talked about I've talked about
the ways in which that's problematic but
I guess if we imagine this spectrum that
you've talked about which is theoretical
physics on one side and let's imagine
Gender Studies at the other who decides
where the
is drawn between what is legitimate for
academic departments to teach and study
and what isn't okay in a if you were to
go back 50 years that question would be
easy
you'd say does this stuff pass peer
review does it muster a is are there
lines of literature on this but we can't
do that anymore
it's almost like phrenology like if they
were a discipline you know when they
look the shape of the head and such and
they extrapolate and make inferences
about one's intelligence and race and
such right it's been debug so if we look
at what's happening now in gender
studies these people are making their
own journals admittedly this isn't just
you under studies but you in gender
sense you find the worst example yeah
we're taught we can focus on that since
it's it's a good one for us to discuss
yeah so you find people making their own
journals publishing in their own
journals becoming promoted and receiving
tenure because they've promoted in their
own journals but just do the same thing
I mean physicist I feel like we're in a
Seinfeld episode dentists have their own
schools physicists have their own
journals and those journals and
publication in those journals is also
used right I guess what I'm kind of
drill down at is how do we effectively
distinguish okay we'll look but the
difference in physics is we can make
assessments about physical phenomena of
the world and those are empirical
questions gender studies is dealing with
moral issues and they're making moral
pronouncements of issues and they're
backing this up by their own invented
corpus of literature and again I'm on
board with most of most of these
conclusions or looking you get all
training and treatment of people try to
render people homeless I'm on board with
that but that is not the role of an
active active edition that is certainly
not the role of an academic department
that makes a mockery of our institutions
because it turns the peer review process
into a sham and they'll reap the way
that it does that and then I'll get back
to your issue of defunding the way that
it does that is they manufacture they're
morally motivated
they manufacture their own lines of
discipline they get promoted in tenure
and when you attempt to call them out on
this this is gets back to the earlier
segment we did about faith they believe
anyway right they're going to believe in
they here's here's an example
do we want to defund gimme example of
the discipline do we want to fund
engineering well no okay yeah yeah well
because we there are actual bridges you
go in and you learn a skill about the
world it is an empirical skill okay
that's your fixed spot I mean here's
really what I'm wondering if we can sort
of talk this through together and see if
we end up at the same place are you in
agreement that gender is important to
homosapians in other words when we think
about Homo sapiens and the culture that
Homo sapiens live in is gender relevant
I would think of course it is everything
it is okay generally is there academic
value to studying issues of important to
Homo sapiens yeah and I know where
you're going well we're ongoing is where
I'm going is it sounds like you disagree
with a lot of what it the way in which
gender studies is being taught maybe the
people that are teaching it the way in
which you believe maybe there's this
closed loop of sort of credentialing of
gender studies through internal peer
review you know their own journals so to
speak but it's hard for me to make the
case based on what you just said which
is gender is a very relevant element of
human society and that it's important to
academically study issues of importance
to human society based on that alone
it's hard for me to argue there should
not be gender studies departments okay
so some of the best research on gender
does not come from gender studies
departments they come from sociology
departments if you want a rough guide to
figure out whether or not a discipline
is legitimate ask yourself and by
legitimate I mean correlated facts to
external reality ask yourself if the
methodologies they use there are pistol
mala geez if you will
are manufactured or they're not so for
example bridge building to get that to
engineering and and most most
disciplines out of humanities the hard
sciences we use the scientific method if
you want to justify a moral conclusion
that you make but you can't do it you
can't reason your way to it one thing
that we see now in post-modernism
disciplines infected by post-modernism
is that they make up their own
methodologies to justify their
conclusions for example Auto ethnography
is a and I would urge your viewers to
google and look up Auto ethnography
because it's just so crazy Auto
ethnography is the idea that you
basically do self interviews and relate
them to the literature in some way it's
your own and then the the bought the
body of literature on Auto ethnography
and the individual papers coming out
about Auto ethnography will absolutely
blow your mind okay that's fair but just
just to keep us laser focused if we can
it's not like we're in a blurry area in
the sense that you don't like gender
studies has taught by gender studies
departments but you're conceding that
gender studies is important to human
society and there is importance gender
is important and and then I will tell
you something that I find fascinating if
you don't mind gender is important I
look at I think that I think there was
overwhelming evidence that these I mean
let me say something I cannot tell you
why this is but I find this to be
absolutely fascinating my wife is an
anthropologist and she has a an MD that
somewhat beside the plug but when she
was in getting an MD PhD she met many
people working in cross-cultural women's
issues and I like the work of these
people I'm not going to tell you the
name specifically so I said to my wife I
would like to use this person at these
people as an example of somebody who's
doing really good work on gender in this
particular example and I'll tell you why
I'm not going to give you specifics in a
moment this woman worked at the
intersection of Public Health Policy and
transgender issues and AIDS social some
really good stuff about travesties in
Brazil etc so my wife said well why
don't you call her up and make sure it's
okay that you use her name and I said
love absolutely someone wanted to use my
name and my work I do I absolutely so I
called her up said who I was she said
I'm an you know and and I said like you
use your name and she said no and I said
really and she said no I'm just not
comfortable with that I said okay can
you give me the exam can you please give
me three or four examples of people you
consider to be doing good work in gender
studies or with gender in particular and
she said no and I thought wow that's
really interesting and then I just kind
of wrote it off as an anomaly I have
subsequently asked two additional people
people I respected whose work I respect
if I could maybe I'm too controversial
figure I don't know or if they could
recommend somebody else a version of
what's called snowball sampling but you
know can you recommend somebody else's
work that I can read or that I can look
at and both of those people said no so
there's some that that's very
interesting to me and you know maybe
academics but I think that there's
something in the nature of this field
that is absolutely toxic at its core so
much so that people really don't want
their work subject to any scrutiny
because at base I think they're
pretending I think that they are morally
motivated IEL ideologues and they
realize at its core that the work coming
out of their departments is not based in
reality it isn't these are activists who
are masquerading as academic as back in
traditions all right well your your
point of view on that coming through
loud and clear let's pause there with
dr. Peter Magowan
more after the break let's continue our
conversation with dr. Peter Bogosian
Peter an issue that I'm very interested
in because I think that it is very often
portrayed inaccurately
on the political spectrum
by both sides is that issue of what is
often called white privilege now you've
written about white privilege for our
conversation I want to restrict our
conversation to the United States
specifically and I think it will sort of
become relevant why as we go on do you
know the leaders that in the United
States in 2017 there is any degree of
what is colloquially referred to as
white privilege yet can I ask what you
mean by that because we may mean
different things by that I guess by
white privilege I mean an unearned
deference that one has by virtue of
being or being perceived as and the
perceived as will be relevant to our
conversation in a majority white country
by virtue of being perceived as white do
I think that that confers social urge
confers advantages on people sort yeah I
do
so talk a little bit about where you see
white privilege as a real thing and
where you think that some assertions
about white privilege sort of go off the
rails well this is a huge conversation
15 how long do we well its site I mean I
think let's consider it an overview
conversation something we might dig into
in more detail at some future point so
is it more or less so this is an
empirical question to which I did not
have the data tell to have my area of
expertise but this is a way that one
would think about the problem is it more
or less likely that somebody who's black
or perceived as black would be pulled
over by the police for a minor
infraction in a vehicle than somebody
who's white or perceived as white might
my hunch would be to say yes although I
watched a Larry elder Andy Rubin video
that really made me think that my belief
in this could be might not be as
evidence-based as it is and I have to
say I don't have the evidence but I do
have what I think of good ways to think
about the problem so
and then what are the what are the
consequences of that what are the
consequences for the criminal justice
system I mean we know by and large that
the criminal justice system is geared
toward money so if you're wealthy you
have more opportunities to get off even
if you're guilty frankly then than if
you're not and we know that that poverty
is I wouldn't say endemic in the black
community but I would certainly say
statistically there are larger numbers
of african-americans living in poverty
in our a percentage of whites so I do
think that white privilege is something
that's real it may correspond to
economics it may also correspond to the
fact that black on black crimes are
perceived as so again that the whole
issue is just so charged that we have we
have really created a I noticed that I'm
being far more judicious in my words
because I know that any misstatement or
anything that I can say will be
perceived as something else I don't
think we're ready to have an honest
conversation about this I think in turn
off or I mean just totally like an
anecdote you know I feel like I have
white privilege despite being unclear as
to as to whether I'm white and what I
mean by that is I'm a Hispanic immigrant
to the United States or whose ethnicity
I'm from Argentina my ethnicity is
Ashkenazi Jewish right and I am sort of
and I use the term lucky maybe it's not
the exact right term but I have
benefited from the reality that I moved
to the US when I was five instead of ten
and thus lost my accent when speaking
English and because my ancestry
ethnically is European Ashkenazi Jewish
I also am perceived as white now social
class being the same education would be
envisioned like excuse me visually
perceived as white visually perceived as
one yeah so holding my social class
level and sort of my education level the
same as it is I am very aware that when
I have an interact
with police my ability to say what I
think is concerning about their behavior
if I see them harassing someone on the
street or when they show up at a loud
wedding party that I'm at like I was at
last week if I had darker skin and had
learned English five years later and
thus had an accent my intelligence would
be the same my social class you know
holding everything else equal my
relationship with the police might be
different my comfort level in being
sarcastic or indifferent would be
different so I think that this is sort
of an interesting idea that I've lived
myself you know yeah I think everything
you said well I don't have any evidence
for I don't have faith in it I think
it's probably true
nothing is probably true look if I may
interject something else this is kind of
a secret I don't want anybody to know
but it's a good reveal on your show if
you think having white privilege is
something waiting to get to be my age
then you actually see it I mean that you
know gray hair older guy privilege is
awesome
interesting and again I mean people
everybody it seems like just yesterday
I'd walk into a store when I was a
teenager and people think I'm gonna
steal stuff and a little while ago I was
in store and someone said oh sir I need
to leave can you watch the store for me
what uh but yeah even when you go
somewhere you know like I go and I don't
have my ID on me and I need to go to a
bar a few drinks and I just point to my
head and giggle okay um but I have
definitely felt old age or older age I
don't think I'm old age yet but I
definitely felt middle-aged privilege
among the police people calling
everybody calls me sir so I think that
there are definitely you can extrapolate
outward from that and you can listen to
the sincere testimony or when people say
look you know I don't feel comfortable
and it's not just the police I think
it's a general attitude I think that
police have an extremely difficult job
and they're caught between some bad laws
like some drug laws and enforcing those
laws and they're caught between the fad
this is when we get this is when the
conversation gets very tricky but now
and not tricky in terms of facts but
just tricky in terms of the political
implications that one draws from those
facts
I think that the if you look at the
majority of you just need to look at the
majority of crimes specifically violent
crimes and murders and I think that that
and again I don't have access those to
these data and I'm happy to change my
mind but it is my impression that a
black man is far more likely to be
killed by another black man than a white
man is to be killed by a black man well
that on that that's true but where that
often goes off the rails is that if you
are white you're basically just as
likely to be the victim of another white
person a grieving you then anybody are
black and you know it's basically
interracial violence is what happening
that's just because there are more wipes
that's just a statistical thing well
there's more White's who could be
victims and more whites who could be
perpetrators in the same way right i
mean it's proportional well if you look
at the number of homicides again again
i'm getting out of my area now so i'm a
little little artists about speaking
about this stuff but if you look at the
number of homicides and here's how we
know that of black people who have been
killed by other black people and then we
look at we max those two the
incarceration rates of black people and
said well how do you know it wasn't
someone else's because we get that from
the eyewitness testimony of people who
perceive other people's races a certain
link and say well that testimony is
biased okay maybe it is I don't really
know I'm not an expert on witness
testimony but I think it's very
difficult for the police because they're
trying to do the job and I think we have
to ascribe excuse me good motivations to
the overwhelming majority of police
officers they're trying to do an
incredibly difficult job and save
people's lives and they're confronted by
some pretty ghastly statistics that
accord with their own personal
experiences and look this is what I
think we should do you want to know
here's why things to do yeah and here's
why I think what I think we should do
will absolutely never in a million years
happen and this will tell you how toxic
our current environment is we need to
have experts on and I am NOT one of
these people by any stretch of
imagination we need to have experts on
policing and the rules of police
and public policy and when forces using
one and we need to have those people
have a discussion maybe even debate if
you want with Jimmy activists in the
community I black lives matter I
wouldn't say so but and we need to have
that conversation at a university and we
need to have a civil conversation and we
need to really see for the urban Harbor
must calls mutual understanding could
you fathom that happening
they'll be practically speaking pretty
difficult yeah I mean it would be pretty
tough no it would not even be deferred
it would not it would be you could never
have that conversation so we I think I
can do it I think I could moderate that
and have some degree of success if we
had the right people in the room I would
love for you to treat you do this I'll
fly out to be CEO teach ABC you say look
I would love to see the administrators
face when you tell them I I think that
we should have a that I would like to
moderate a conversation between people
now get actual policemen not people were
professors who theorize about the police
get people who are actually involved in
these decisions and it can explain to
people and then get people on the other
side of the room try to bring them
together have a civil conversation I
don't think any administrator will
approve it because I don't think we're
ready to have those conversations I
think that people are afraid that
violence will erupt and I think there's
a good reason people are afraid that
violence will erupt but that's the kind
of conversation we need we need to have
mutual under seat you to understanding
between members of the community and
members of the police for example why
should you when the police and even I do
this with my grey hair for let's when
when the police pull you over why should
you keep your hands on the steering
wheel well you should keep your hands on
the steering wheel because there have
been many instances and I've seen them
I've seen these videos myself where
people then pull guns out and shoot the
cops so we need to look at this issue
from both sides and I don't think it's
simply as easy as systemic racism I
think that the police have an incredibly
difficult job to do but to get back to
your earlier point I do think there's
white privilege I do think that there's
value and meaning and talking about that
and I do think that if we're honest
about that and we can communicate about
that then we can go
healing is a goofy word but it really is
the word that applies we can try to heal
these deep divisions one more thing we
can do that by appealing to super what's
called in the literature super identity
so super entities we're all Americans
remember right after 9/11 from the
others time everybody was super civil
and you want to get into traffic people
that you go that lasted about ten days
maybe two weeks tops but we can appeal
to commonalities that we have so that we
can solve these problems that's why the
most important thing that we can do is
to have a conversation and David you
would be that really you really would be
among the most perfect people to attempt
to broker that conversation if you could
do that you would really have something
extraordinary on your hands well I can't
think of a better place to take our last
break than that we will wrap up with dr.
Peter Boghossian next we've been
speaking today with dr. Peter Boghossian
full-time faculty member in Portland
State University's philosophy department
also author of the book a manual for
creating atheists Peter when you take a
sort of broader look as to what's going
on in American politics you know
everybody has their sort of general
assessment what put Trump in the White
House what does this mean for the future
of one political party or the other
political party stepping back from the
sort of day-to-day politics and firings
and scandals and whatever the case may
be do you agree with me that we are
increasingly separating the political
world from any sense of epistemology
critical thinking the importance of the
facts as we can know them over the last
I don't know six months five years ten
years like a unit are you on board with
me and that departure that we're seeing
univocal
we are speak as one voice absolutely
unshakably convinced of that what do you
attribute that to because there are
partisan people who say hey listen the
Democrats are the party of facts and the
Republicans aren't so you've got a party
that in order to get elected is going to
move away from facts there's another
slightly more general view which is we
have growing pseudo and anti
intellectualism and that's what is
reinforcing sort of pride in not dealing
with the facts I don't know I mean what
do you
think we can point to I don't know so
the rise of social media anonymous
accounts the fact that I I know honestly
I don't know I could only hypothesize
the answer to that I don't know I do
find the deep divides and the inability
to have conversation with people and
ending of friendships over that in fact
that's my next book is about how to have
conversations across the divide and
possible conversations I think we need
to take a look and work collaboratively
with people but in this current
political environment it's almost
impossible I think Trump is a I don't
even know the adjectives I can describe
for how unhinged he is I used to think
that that pence was worse I'm reading
that belief but I do think that we need
to reinforce I don't know what's causing
this intense polarization I just can't
answer that question
I mean the problem I have is that
everything you're saying is true but
sometimes what you're saying is is used
to point to both sides are just as valid
on every issue every opinion on every
issue has to be heard and as you know
when you talk about good epistemologies
and bad epistemologies in your book
that's not the case and that's where I
think that the general discussions about
polarization often lead us nowhere
because they reinforce a need for false
balance on every issue no that's a great
question as integration now first of all
everybody has a microphone so
everybody's voice is equal as mine is
James Lindsey said to me the most
important thing for us to do in this age
is determine is to determine whose voice
doesn't matter whose voice doesn't
matter so everybody has a microphone the
Democrats have been held hostage to
identity politics which is one of the
worst things they had like a complete
failure to acknowledge that many of
their tactics and beliefs particularly
as it regards to identity politics and
intersectionality have been directly
responsible for the rise of Trump I
don't think it's the case that
I think we tend to paint with these
broad brushes I think that they're the
Republicans do tend to be more anti
science and particularly in regard to
environmental issues and the problem
with that is that those are those might
be with us for a very very very long
time and there's something about what
Trump is doing environmentally now if
you were to put everything he's doing in
a basket of crazy versus the
environmental stuff you know decreasing
our standing in the world you name it
he's he's got that in spades in terms of
anything that's negative the
environmental stuff I think would over
weigh all of that and unless we can
figure out how to talk to ourselves or
talk with each other I don't think we're
going to get anywhere I don't think the
smearing the name-calling I don't think
any of that stuff is productive and
helping us solve any I can't think of
any problem in which screeching at
someone is either going to make them
more likely to change their mind or to
solve the problem factor even I'm going
to go beyond that we do not even have
the ability we are not even honest in
our conversations anymore because we're
afraid if we make one misstep or if we
say well one wrong thing we're going to
be branded as a racist or bigoted or as
a homophobe I think these are terrible
problems in which we look what's
happening to Sam Harris you can't even
have conversations with people or Dave
Rubin you can't even ask certain
questions and if you do either people if
you veer from the orthodoxy then the
people on your own tribe will attack you
or if you say something that other
people find unpalatable they'll just
smear you in is that is that I asked
Dave Rubin this last week is that as big
of a problem as some are making it out
to be like just as an example like for
example I share your concerns with
radical elements of third wave feminism
intersectionality sort of these
unproductive versions of identity
politics the safeSpace trigger warning
stuff and as I put it to Dave Rubin I'll
put it to you can we agree on the
problem but also come to some better
understanding of the degree to which it
exists because I think that that's where
I differ more with
folks like you and Dave Rubin not as to
whether these issues are problematic but
the degree to which they exist and you
I'm not sure I understand
in other words like how big I guess let
me rephrase it this way I agree with you
that every issue you cited as a problem
is a problem however I'd likely hear
more about how you determine the degree
to which it's a problem and how
prevalent it is because I think that the
example among the left some of these
issues they're problems but they're
relatively isolated issues well they're
problems because one you have a bunch of
extraordinarily vocal people who make it
look like they're in the majority who
but are probably still in the minority
correct and unfortunately right it
didn't give you a great example so ITA
been on sabbatical for a year I teach
ethics and if you really want to teach
ethics right if you truly want to get
people to challenge their moral views
and question things to think about their
beliefs you have to talk about how
issues you have to talk about
transgender bathrooms you have to talk
about factory farming you have to talk
about Peter s Tanner's the Australian
philosopher Peter saying this what
should we do with people who have IQs
under 25 no one's willing to talk about
this stuff and you know they're not
willing to talk about this stuff because
they don't want to deal with the
complaints because students are so
brittle that they have never heard the
other side of the issue so I think it
depends where you are and what kind of
conversations you're having you know I
think it also depends upon the people
with whom you're speaking is there some
way that this could be dealt with at an
earlier point and the reason I'm asking
that question is specifically when we
see for example what's going on with
Texas textbooks and the total
elimination of critical thinking as a
course that is even available
hypothetically in high schools wouldn't
we attack the college issue more
successfully if there was critical
thinking being taught in high school and
why is it that it's overwhelmingly
Republicans that don't want it taught in
high school well one it's because
they're pretending to know something
they don't know like if you thought you
had the truth you wouldn't prostatitis
anybody they'd come you could rationally
those principles on your own if you
honestly believe for example in
Christianity or whatever superstition
you happen to believe in you wouldn't
need to do that so there is definitely a
component of Republicans the Republican
Party has more or less been hijacked by
and you can perfectly see this the way
that plays out with who Trump pander to
his bad audience has been hijacked by
religious maniacs and you see that
manifest across the board the left is
also culpable in that in terms of what
they're doing in the Academy there's
something here at Portland State
University that was amazing to me and
that was excuse me they had a speaking
event in which anybody could attend but
whites were not allowed to ask questions
blew my mind I asked my buddy who's an
appellate court judge I said I can't
believe this is legal he said yeah it's
totally legal but it's a horrible idea
because then they could because then
that would mean that they would have to
have situations in which whites could
present blacks could attend but blacks
weren't allowed to ask any questions so
I see this that's why I think the term
regressive is good because we're
regressing to separate but equal we're
regressing to these points that
hopefully we had overcome but but
evidently not I mean I think it's an
enormous problem and at the root of the
whole problem I think that the thing
that helps us to think about this is we
need to think about these things in
terms of this is a secular religion they
have all the hallmarks of a secular
religion they have blasphemy they have
speech political correctness
they have original sin which is
privileged which is what we started this
episode is off so I think if we look at
it in terms of that we're really seeing
the emergence of another religion that's
the end of our time today we've been
speaking with dr. Peter Bogosian
full-time faculty member at Portland
State University's philosophy department
the book a manual for creating atheist
has been the subject of some of our
conversation today Peter always great to
talk to you thank you thank you very
much and we also have an app a Theo's a
th us app com that puts a lot of these
principles into action for how to have
effective conversations